if we are going to be human and to
experience the modalities of being and
experienced as the keyword if we're
going to experience the modalities of
being and you have to write these things
into your script somewhere and we know
this is obvious to everyone who's deeply
involved with these things we would need
Iowa's Karos auth in the bush and the
guy would say señores you are great
Delta X great scientists but the primary
thing is the experience and we said yes
we know we'll sit at your feet as you
show us how to make it we have no
illusions we know that the primary thing
is the experience and so it's your own
life it's a dialogue between you and
being its authentic being not canned
being it's not an ideology it's not a
teaching that comes from some August
being that you can never hope to be like
who's handing it down to you it's you
you must recognize yourself as the
primary focus the primary vehicle for
unraveling what's going on and then the
psychedelics emerge as having major
paramount importance
in your life
you